Outfront tonight. A star witness
speaks to CNN. Robert Costello
is the witness. Trump's team
pushed for the Manhattan da's
hush money investigation, and he
is speaking out tonight to our
Paula Reid and revealing new
details about the three hours
that he spent behind closed
doors with the grand jury
investigating hush money
payments to adult film star
stormy Daniels. Now Costello was
a legal advisor to the D a star
witness, Michael Cohen. And
after testifying, Costello said
this. I've listened to Michael
Cohen stand in front of the
courthouse and say things that
are directly contrary to what he
said to us. My obligation is to
bring the truth to both the
district attorney and to trump's
lawyers. That's exactly what I
did. Now we know that Costello's
testimony was so important that
district attorney Alvin Bragg is
considering bringing Michael
Cohen there's a dueling doing
witnesses here back for a third
time to testify before that same
grand jury, so Costello's
conversation with our polarized
is important and you're going to
hear much more from her in just
a moment because this all comes
as again tonight. The entire
country is waiting to see
whether trump is about to be
charged and arrested or not,
right. It's been this waiting
game. So why is the D a not
moving ahead yet? The grand jury
did meet again today, but this
is really interesting. Sources
tell CNN that they didn't even
discuss trump. And the D. A
Alvin Bragg today was in a war
of words with trump, the former
president, sending out an email
to supporters saying quote day
Alvin brags expected indictment
of trump resembles Stalin's
notorious tactics. Trump also
reposted an article which is a
picture of trump holding a bat
next to a picture of brag. As
for Bragg, he's accusing the
former president of whipping his
supporters into a frenzy by
claiming he was going to be
arrested on Tuesday, which trump
did right. He said he was gonna
be arrested on Tuesday. He's the
one who said that expectation.
And the general counsel for
brags office and a letter to
house Republicans who are now
vowing to investigate brags as
quote Donald Trump created a
false expectation that he would
be arrested the next day, and
his lawyers reportedly urged you
to intervene. Paula Reid begins
our coverage outfront she's
outside the cover the courthouse
in New York and Paula. You did
have this conversation with
Costello, which is so crucial
because he is at the heart of
this entire situation right now.
What did he tell you? Larry and
I called him to talk about what
happened in that grand jury room
could have prompted prosecutors
to then take a step back and
determine if they want to bring
back Michael Cohen or some other
witness to rebut his testimony,
and he described what happened
in the grand jury room as
contentious at times, he said
before his appearance he had
given prosecutors hundreds of
documents. But he was only asked
about six of them. He said. He
challenged the prosecutor on why
these weren't all being admitted
as evidence, he said. At one
point, he even looked at the
grand jury and told them, he
said, you guys need to get all
of these documents. And he says
that five or six of the jurors
actually nodded in agreement. He
tells me that he believes that
his testimony absolutely had an
impact. On the grand jury, and I
asked him well, who is the
witness that they could
potentially bring into about
this testimony, he said. It's
absolutely not Michael Cohen,
and when I asked if there were
any other names, he says,
there's no one. It's impossible
to refute what I said. He said
he hasn't heard from the
district attorney since he
testified Monday. So all right.
That's interesting and
interesting. I mean, the color
he's giving you all right. This
is what he's telling you that
you know. Five or six people
were nodding along when he said
that more information was
needed. Obviously, there's 23.
They need a supermajority, you
know to go ahead and bring these
charges that there does appear
Paula to be a holding pattern
with the grand jury. I mean,
that's certainly what it feels
like. Right this has been going
on now for almost a week, and
you have new reporting on what's
going on. That's exactly right.
It feels like that, because
based on our reporting, that is
the case right now. Prosecutors
are taking a moment to regroup.
They are really contemplating
the potentially historic
decision that they have in front
of them to possibly indict for
the first time, a former U. S
president now we know they did
not hear any evidence about the
trump case today, but the jury
will reconvene on Monday when
they are expected to once again
hear evidence about the trust
trump hush money probe they may
also hear from a witness, but
it's unclear Aaron if they will
move to then vote on a possible
indictment. That at this point
is just unclear, so we'll be
back here Monday, reporting it
out. Well all right, Paula.
Thank you very much with all of
that new reporting and Paul
again, having a chance to
actually speak to Costello
herself. Ryan Goodman is
outfront Karin agness. Follow
Stephanie Rawlings, Blake and
Scott Jennings all with me here
to talk about this. So when you
hear Paula, she spoke to
Costello today, and it does seem
from everything we know that his
testimony on Monday is causing a
problem for bragging. Something
in there did not go the way they
expected it to go. You know, it
may be the case. I mean, at some
level, I think that brags office
probably anticipated a lot of
what Costello would say because
they've just been doing this
work for a great deal of time,
but it does make sense that if
they do want to rebut his
testimony, they might want to
bring somebody else back in. The
statement that he has also made
out on the street in front of
the courthouse is something
that's rebuttable. He says.
Nothing irrefutable, but he says
that you know, this whole thing
was Michael Cohen's idea. Will
you know David pecker, who has
already appeared before the
grand jury through his company,
American media incorporated,
they submitted a statement to
the federal prosecutors, which
said that they were in on the
scheme with Michael Cohen to set
up the hush money payments, and
they were doing it to suppress
stories from coming up before
the election. That might be a
good person that they'd want to
bring in and that's what they
need to consider Karen. What do
you think is causing this delay.
I think exactly what Ryan just
said. I think they're
considering what evidence they
need to put in to shore up the
case and to rebut what what was
said by trump's witness, Mr
Costello. I also think they
probably wanted for security
reasons to not have too much
time between a vote, an
indictment as well. And then a
surrender because you have to
keep the president, the former
president say if you have to
keep new yorkers safe, and it
will it will leak out if by no
one else other than trump, it
will leak out and he will drop.
Up. Protesters and potentially
create another January 6th. So
if I were the district attorney
, I'd be consulting with law
enforcement so that we can we
can have a little daylight
between the vote, the indictment
and his surrender surrender. You
know, it is interesting, though
. Um, mayor, you know Costello
again. This is how he
characterized it, so that's all
you have to go on. But he told
Paula five or six of the of the
members of the grand jury were
nodding when he said, you need
to demand more information.
There needs to be more
paperwork. Look, they only need
a majority of 23 to indict. But
as has been very clear when I
said supermajority, that's not
the requirement, but that's what
is perceived to be necessary. In
this case, you gotta show with
the grand jury that it's bay
close to unanimous, if not
unanimous. So what is this all
say to you? It says to me that
the trump team is very
disciplined in their efforts to
create chaos, Costello said what
he needed to say they want to
murky the waters. They want to
make it. So anything that
bragged does will be perceived
by trump supporters as a
political, um, political
decision and I think they're
doing a good job of it. So you
know, it's interesting, though,
Scott, you know, on the on the
democratic side, there's been
caution, right? Chuck Schumer
didn't come out and say I
support everything. The D eight
is. Yeah, I said, I'll wait and
see what happens, right? I mean,
they've been incredibly cautious
not to necessarily back him not
to back. What's going to happen.
Republican side no such caution,
right? They've been coming out
full throated behind trump and
house Republicans. You know,
they're demanding information,
um, is bragging to have to
answer to congress. Maybe uh I
mean, they have the power to do
things like this, and I think
they needed to show their
constituents their supporters
that they were standing up for
trump. I mean, the truth is the
entire Republican party. Even
the people who don't want trump
back are are in lockstep on
this. They think this whole
thing is political and on a
weaponization of the criminal
justice system, and I do think
there's a chunk of Democrats who
would really rather brag, not go
forward. By the way on the van
Jones is one of them. I mean,
many of them are very open about
it. I mean, I think there's
plenty of Democrats and maybe
even some Republicans. We think
it would be better for the other
cases to go first. On the issue
of creating chaos. I don't see
it that way. In fact, I look at
all the personalities involved
in this. Michael Cohen stormy
Daniels, Donald Trump Costello
seems like the only straight
player to me. I mean, he seemed
like the most credible guy in
the whole bunch. And if he's the
one who went in and gave